A lot of people don’t know is that any number
you’ve ever heard about police violence
comes through the aggregate of media reports.
If you get killed in this country and a newspaper
doesn’t write about it, it’s not covered
on like a blog or like a TV or something,
you literally don’t exist in the data set.
The federal government doesn’t collect information
about police killings in any systemic way.
We can tell you the rainfall in Missouri in
1830, and we can’t actually tell you how
many people got killed, like, as a hard fact
last year.
We don’t know it.
What we know is like the aggregate of media
reports, these incredible activists years
ago set up these two big databases that essentially
called like an advanced Google alerts of like
police killings, and that is the source data
for everything that you’ve ever seen on
police killings.
Some of the biggest databases that you might
have heard of are like the Washington Post
Database, fatal encounters killed by police.
We created Mapping Police Violence to create
the single stop database that had the most
comprehensive data about police killings.
If you think about the Washington Post Database,
for instance, they only have killings by officers
on duty that use a gun.
So say for example an officer goes home and
runs somebody over with their car, like that’s
not counted.
Say somebody is on duty and the officer runs
you over with their car, not accounted.
Eric Garner’s death is not in the Washington
Post Database.
Why?
Because he wasn’t killed with a gun.
So we wanted to say that like whether you
got killed by a taser, a chokehold, whether
the officer was at home and like killed his
wife off-duty, we consider all of those to
be symptoms of the same sort of root problem.
So that’s why we created the database.
And what we know is that, left to their own
devices, that police will just never report
this data.
There are times where the state of Florida
has reported zero police killings in entire
spans of years, and you’re like “We know
that’s not true, like we could just look
at the news and see it wasn’t zero!”
So the data actually is really important for
us to help locate what the problem is and
what the solution should be.
And the last thing I’ll say is that we have
to figure out how to start talking about police
violence beyond death.
So we know that the police inflict damage
in communities in ways like sexual assault,
verbal abuse, those sort of things, and the
data we have most readily available is about
death, but because we only focus on death
with the data, we’re losing how the police
impact women, how the police impact LGBT communities,
like any other ways that don’t result in
death but are still really bad—and we have
to figure out how to do that.
One of the limitations is that most police
departments definitely don’t make that data
publicly available or don’t collect it in
any systemic way.
So you think about police departments like
Baltimore where so much of the data is on
paper, you’re like “Well, who is sitting
down analyzing ten million records on paper?
Nobody right now,” and that becomes like
a challenge.
So what we found were a couple myth busters.
We found things like there’s this idea that
community violence and police violence are
related, so in communities where there’s
just a lot of violence people say that “the
police just have to be there, because the
communities are violent and so the police
must be there.
And because the police must be there it’s
just more likely that they’ll probably engage
in violence against communities.”
And we found that that’s just not true.
There are places where there’s a lot of
community violence and almost no police violence,
and the inverse is also true that there’s
no real relationship between community violence
and police violence.
We also found is that black people are actually
more likely to be unarmed than any other race
of people who are killed by police.
So there’s this myth that black people are
just like carrying guns around and like they’re
in the presence of police, and that actually
isn’t true.
And with regard to policy we found out a lot
of things.
So we created the first public database of
use of force policies and police union contracts
in the country because we were trying to figure
out like why are the police not accountable?
Is it really that prosecutors and mayors just
don’t care?
Like what is it?
What we found is that there’s literally
just a different justice system.
So you think about places like in Maryland,
in Maryland the law literally says that a
citizen can file an anonymous complaint against
an officer for everything except brutality.
I don’t even know what that means.
In California there is a law that says that
any investigation of an officer that lasts
more than a year can never result in discipline.
Like I don’t even know what that means.
In places like in Baton Rouge you can’t
file a complaint over the phone against an
officer.
There are places where you have to file an
affidavit, like where would you go to get
an affidavit today?
I don’t know.
There are all these things that almost guarantee
that officers won’t be held accountable,
and we shed light on them for the first time
with this big database trying to help people
see like - and actually you could get a great
prosecutor, but if the rules are set up against
everybody the great prosecutor is still hamstrung.
You can get a mayor, you can get a city council,
but if we don’t focus on these structural
things that aren’t necessarily the most
“sexy,” but if they’re actually the
most salient in terms of outcomes like we’ll
never win.
And that’s why we created Mapping Police
Violence to get the data and then Campaign
Zero to talk about the policies and solutions
that actually might change the system of accountability.
So we made the first valid database of use
of force policies in the country and it was
hard to get good—Use of Force policies,
for people that don’t know, are essentially
the rules that police use to say whether they
can use force against somebody, anything up
to (and leading to) death or murder.
And what we found is that, A, it was just
really hard to get the record.
So our data set right now is the hundred biggest
cities in the country and some places sent
us back almost entirely redacted policies,
some places, after a long battle we got them,
and what we found are a couple of things:
one is that one of the things that we look
for is do you ban chokehold?
We know that there are almost no instances
where like it makes sense for an officer to
restrict somebody’s airway.
We also found that there’s some slipperiness
that happens and New York City is a great
example of like chokeholds are banned in New
York City.
“Eric Gardner,” the police would say,
“was not put me in a chokehold, he was put
in a stranglehold and strangleholds aren’t
banned in New York City.”
And you’re like people experience them all
the same, he still died.
So we mapped that across places.
We also map is there a continuum of force?
Is there like an officer has to use a verbal
warning then use something else?
There is a lot of places where there isn’t
a continuum, it’s sort of like you just
use force, and you’re like “Well that
doesn’t really make a lot of sense.”
We also mapped to look at: can you shoot in
moving cars?
What we find is that when you look at the
data the police would have you believe that
they respond, that they’re always responding
to bank robberies, like every single 911 call
is a bank robbery, and the data just actually
doesn’t support that.
So when you see some of the stuff that is
leading to these car chases it actually just
isn’t worth the collateral damage.
It’s not worth somebody getting shot, their
legs still being on the gas, and them running
pedestrians over.
Like none of it is worth it.
Especially in a time where there’s like
helicopters, like if you wanted to find the
person you’re probably going to find them,
so we should ban shooting into moving vehicles.
Like we are mapping all of these things so
that we can say to departments, A, we know
that there’s a problem in your city because
we have the data on police violence.
B, there is structural things that you can
actually change that statistically suggest
that they’ll have a better outcome in those
places, so we mapped them.
Does your partner have to intervene if they
see you using force unnecessarily?
We think that they should.
Do you have to engage lesser force before
you use lethal force?
We think you should.
We’re up against a system that’s really
challenging.
The police for decades have been taught something
called the 21-foot rule.
I don’t know if you’ve ever heard of the
21-foot rule, but they get trained that if
somebody is within 21 feet of you they can
kill you.
That’s like the rule that they get trained.
So you’re like, why did you shoot the guy
with a knife?
And they’re like “we were trained that
if they’re within 21 feet of us they can
run quick enough to kill you.”
And you’re like, who is making this stuff
up?
And like it’s been disproven.
It’s like crackpot science, but those things
are actually like really dangerous and we
wanted to say :what are the policies and solutions
that either lead to these outcomes or that
we can change?